Bảo dưới điện khem liên mục bài thân tâm cho biết, Ngà và Mỹ đã nhất chỉ về nguyên tác định điểm tổ chức của gặp thương định,
giữa tổng thống là đi mê phù chiến và người đồng tóc đường đơn tròa.
Giờ kiến xin xa trong tổng tới, xe kiến này đánh giống nấu lực nối lại đối thoại tâm cao ra anh lớt,
cho bối cảnh quá để sống phương tích tục cân thẳng, vì loạt bất đồng về ăn định, u khuay nè và cạnh tranh chỉ lượng tòn cầu.
Giới chính ngày khẩn định vẫn cần thiền thời gian để hoàn tất khâu chuẩn bị hậu cân và chính thức công bố đi điểm của thế.
Truy đó, tổng thủ của chiến đã có cuộc gặp với đã phải viên Mỹ Steve Khoa tại Más Kheva,
nhằm đặt liên tặng chùi đàn cấp cao.
Thì Mỹ tổng thống đưa tròa bài tỏ lắc quan về khả nâng tổ chức của gặp trong khi ngoại trường mắt khâu rư biểu thời nhận vẫn còn nhiều trường ngày cần thảo gỡ.
Thuy nhiên, được khai bệnh trụ đậm xuất tiến cặp gỡ, cho thấy giống hiệu tích cực trường mỗi lực kiểm soát đồng,
vui chỉ ổn định quan cầu.